an upcoming showdown in the senate over
voting rights president biden says it's
time for senators to declare which side
of history they're on he went further
than ever in support of changing
filibuster rules to get his voting
rights laws through congress his trip to
atlanta yesterday signaled an all-out
lobbying effort to make voting easier in
this country republicans call it a power
grab but some democrats are in fact the
one standing in the way nancy cordes is
at the white house for us nancy good
morning
good morning tony well in a major
escalation of his rhetoric president
biden likened opponents of voting reform
to notorious southern racists suggesting
that they are enemies of the country he
said he now favors changing filibuster
rules but some members of his own party
don't agree
i'm tired of being quiet
a fiery president biden called this a
defining moment in history and after
visiting the grave of the reverend dr
martin luther king jr he argued the
democratic system itself is at stake the
goal of the former president's allies is
to disenfranchise anyone who votes
against them simple as that they'll just
decide what they want
and then do it he was talking about the
laws passed in 19 states imposing new
restrictions on voting the president and
most democrats want to pass a pair of
federal laws that would mandate early
voting and vote by mail in all 50 states
and make election day a national holiday
but republicans are opposed in a
turnaround president biden called for
changing the senate's filibuster rule so
it can pass voting rights bills with a
simple majority we have no option but to
change the senate rules as recently as
last year the president was warning
against changing the rules you're going
to throw the entire congress in the
chaos and nothing will get done senate
republicans slammed his new stance i
expected more
of president biden this power grab is
not about voting right right
instead is it about advancing
one party's agenda and even a few senate
democrats like west virginia's joe
manchin appear poised to block a rule
change
the bus it doesn't make it look better
on tuesday president biden compared
voting rights opponents to
segregationists and confederate leaders
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
this is the moment to decide
senate leader chuck schumer says he is
going to hold votes on this pair of
voting rights bills by next monday
that's the mlk junior holiday if only to
prove that his party cannot pass those
bills unless it changes the filibuster
rules that's the point he wants to make
to that pair of democratic holdouts in
the senate gail
yep that discussion continues thank you
nancy